JAMES JERLECKI: Hi, my name
is James Jerlecki.
I'm the product manager
for TextPlus.
I manage the iOS and Android
engineering teams and also
participated in the new design
of our Android application.
TextPlus is a free texting and
calling application that
allows you to text for free
anywhere in the United States
and Canada.
Because at the end of the day,
that's what TextPlus is.
It's a way for you to send your
emotions to your friends
and family and the people
that you love.
So one of the things I like best
about Google Play is the
Reply to Review feature.
As a product manager and someone
who runs the client
team, it's been a great avenue
for me to one, be able to talk
to our users.
But also incorporate their
feedback into the
application--
whether that is features or
whether that's bugs, anything
to give you more information
to do my job better.
The Reply to Reviews feature has
essentially given me that
direct line that I didn't
have before.
So something else that's
really critical to user
reviews is we make our
engineering teams actually
spend time looking through
and even replying to
the reviews at times.
It really allows the team to
see what the user's saying
about the product they spend
all of their time building.
And we really feel it gives
them extra initiative to
improve the product.
So that's something we love
doing, and we'll do it once a
week or every other week.
And it really just gives the
engineers insight into what
the users are saying.
And also something the Reply
to Reviews has helped us
manage, since we've had access
to this feature, we've
increased daily installs
by roughly 40%.
So it's really key to us to
maintain our overall rating.
So this has allowed us to
monitor the reviews and
respond to customer concerns
quickly and provide feedback,
if they're having an issue
that we can immediately
resolve the user from.
This is a perfect example
of user feedback being
incorporated into the roadmap.
So something that we see in the
reviews almost daily is
personalization.
Sometimes it's tough
being a designer.
You want things to look a
specific way, and you're very
particular about, I want
this background
or I want this asset.
But we've seen it over and over
again, the users have
said, I want customization.
I want to make TextPlus look
how I want it to look.
So something that is coming very
soon and very quickly is
the ability for users to
customize the look
and feel of the app.
So essentially they will be able
to change the background,
change the chat level color,
change the accent color.
So it's truly giving the users
something they want entirely
based on feedback that we
saw in the reviews.
So in Google Play, TextPlus
continues to do very well.
It's actually completely
shifting our business to more
Android first.
And we've increased
our daily installs
roughly 40% since August.
So we're continuing to move in
a very positive direction on
Google Play.